bigquery is one of google cloud's best
loved offerings and if you're a bigquery
fan we've got great news for you we've
made it easier than ever to connect your
massive beast of a data set stored in
bigquery with our ai tools in vertex ai
in this video we'll show you how quickly
you can start exploring your bigquery
data using vertex ai workbench
[Music]
to get started simply go to workbench in
vertex ai to open up a managed notebook
if you had a local.csv file you could
upload it directly into the notebook
folder here but you want more you want
your bigquery data
vertex ai workbench is natively
integrated with bigquery all you need to
do is click on the bigquery connector
icon here on the left
this gives you an instant overview of
all the bigquery tables you have access
to you can follow along with the tables
in your own project or you can try out
any of the 200 plus publicly available
data sets in bigquery to train your own
machine learning models you can also use
this plus button to access additional
data by typing the name of your project
once you pin that project you'll be able
to see the data that you've got access
to in it in this demo i'll work with
public data let's scroll down this data
set called london bicycles strikes my
fancy if you double click on this
bigquery table
you can inspect the metadata see the
schema and preview the table you can
also click generate statistics to get an
overview of the data distributions for
each feature let's click this query
table button right here which will open
up into a query editor with a handy
built-in syntax checker
if you run the query from here you'll
see the results at the bottom but you
want to plug this table into vertex ai
to train your models and you'll be blown
away by how easy that is simply select
this copy code for data frame button
right here and now that you've got that
code copied head back to the launcher
and open up a new python notebook
let's paste out what we just copied
what we've got in front of us is the
boilerplate code to connect to the
bigquery client plus the code that
executes the query that we ran in the
query editor let's go ahead and execute
the cell and then view the data frame
now for those who prefer to skip opening
that sql editor we've got a handy
in-cell query editor with syntax
checking that you can use right in your
notebook and with that
we've turned our bigquery table into a
beautiful pandas data frame that's ready
to go for your ai adventures in your
managed notebook you can learn more in
our vertex ai workbench codelab
now you've got a single interface for
your model development needs sign up to
try it out yourself today free of charge
[Music]
[Music]
you